es herrscht ein großes gedränge auf dem
basar von masar i scharif abdul wahed
macht die einkäufe für seine familie
seine frau und seine kinder schickt er
nicht mehr auf die straße er hat angst
um sie der 34 jährige war jahrelang
dolmetscher bei der bundeswehr mehr denn
je fürchtet er jetzt um seine sicherheit
immer wieder erhält er drohungen erzählt
er
für die taliban ist er einer der mit dem
feind zusammengearbeitet hat ein spion
zurück in seinem haus im zentrum der
stadt
es ist umgeben von hohen mauern auch zum
schutz
ich gehe nicht mehr zu meiner familie
meine nachbarn wissen alle dass ich mit
ausländischen truppen gearbeitet habe
sie denken ich bin reich und deswegen
habe ich auch angst dass meine kinder
entführt werden können
sieben jahre lang hat der 34 jährige für
die bundeswehr gearbeitet
mit dem ende der isaf- mission endete
sein vertrag wie viele ortskräfte
bemühte sich der familienvater nach
deutschland zu gelangen
schon damals hatte er sorgen um seine
sicherheit
inzwischen haben die satz drei kinder in
ihrem haus und dem schönen garten um den
manche sie beneiden sind sie nie
glücklich geworden
seit jahren kämpfen sie darum das land
zu verlassen
und jetzt ist vielleicht ihre letzte
chance
jetzt wo klar ist dass die ausländischen
truppen afghanistan verlassen werden
wird die situation sich noch weiter
verschlimmern
ich fühle mich noch unsicherer in ihrem
wohnzimmer tragen dies sah das alles
zusammen was ihre geschichte beweisen
sollen dokumente auszeichnungen
empfehlungen aus sieben jahren die abdul
wahid bei der bundeswehr gearbeitet hat
als sogenannter sprach vermittler war er
nicht nur dafür da zu übersetzen sondern
auch zwischen deutschen soldaten und
afghanen vertrauen zu schaffen
er zeigt uns fotos aus der zeit an die
er sich gerne erinnert für die
bundeswehr waren ist die schwierigsten
jahre in afghanistan
jahre in denen auch die deutschen immer
häufiger in kämpfe gerieten auch abdul
wahid wäre bei einem einsatz fast ums
leben gekommen und doch hat der
familienvater seinen job sehr gemocht
einsatz für ein besseres afghanistan für
viele ortskräfte endete er 2013
und schon damals gab es proteste direkt
vor dem camp der bundeswehr in
masar-i-scharif an denen auch abdullah
dateiname lasst uns nicht einfach zurück
ihr tragt verantwortung auch für unsere
sicherheit fordern sie nach langem
ringen sichert die bundeswehr
schließlich 850 ort kräften eine
ausreise nach deutschland zu die stars
gehören nicht dazu
doch damit wollen sie sich nicht
abfinden ich habe so viele freunde die
in deutschland leben die von der
regierung dorthin gebracht wurden ich
möchte dort mit meinen freunden leben
ich habe genauso wie sie mit den
deutschen truppen gearbeitet
fast jeden tag gibt es einen anschlag
hier
sie töten unschuldige menschen auch
unser leben ist in gefahr
deshalb möchte ich dass die deutsche
regierung und zur sicherheit nach
deutschland holen
seitdem deutschland im september 2001
truppen an den hindukusch schickt
beschäftigt die bundeswehr afghanische
ortskräfte die sogenannten sprach
vermittler spielten von anfang an eine
große rolle
vor allem im kontakt zur bevölkerung
bilder die in vergessenheit geraten sind
zurzeit sind nur noch 300 kräfte für die
bundeswehr im einsatz
die taliban sagen alle die mit den
ausländern arbeiten sind ungläubige
es sei erlaubt sie zu töten das ziel der
taliban war von anfang an die verbindung
zwischen der afghanischen bevölkerung
und den internationalen truppen zu
zerstören
die übersetzer haben diese verbindung
und brücke hergestellt
deshalb sind wir in besonderer gefahr
wir erleben jetzt bedrohungen die
unvorstellbar sagt sultan ii war
übersetzer bei der bundeswehr
von 2009 bis 2018 auch er blieb mit
seiner familie zurück
obwohl wie er sagt man ihm einen wechsel
nach deutschland in aussicht gestellt
hätte jetzt wollen sie noch einmal
nachweisen dass ihr leben in afghanistan
bedroht ist
[Musik]
ich bin gerade mal 22 und ich habe schon
bluthochdruck wann immer ich messer ist
der sehr hoch seit zwei jahren ist auch
so weil ich ständig an unsere sicherheit
und unser leben denken seit dem sultan
ii erfahren hat dass die bundesregierung
in aussicht stellt bedrohte ortskräfte
mit dem abzug der bundeswehr im sommer
nach deutschland zu holen schöpfen er
uns eine frau hoffnung
wir erwarten von der deutschen regierung
dass sie unsere situation nicht leicht
nimmt sie sollte nicht zuschauen und
abwarten bis jemand getötet wird
in den straßen von masar i scharif ist
der wandel spürbar
afghanische sicherheitskräfte
untersuchen autos nach sprengstoff immer
häufiger verüben radikale islamisten
anschläge auch in großen städten
ein ganzes land lebt in angst arbeit
plant sein haus zu verkaufen
mit seiner frau noch einmal neu
anzufangen auch wenn er seine eltern
zurücklassen muss ein leben in
sicherheit in deutschland
das ist seine zukunftsvision